hey 42 here phobophobia is an intense
fear of developing a phobia when you are
born you only have two fears a fear of
falling and loud noises these are
natural survival mechanisms built into
our DNA and passed down through the
generations every of a fear you face you
have learned throughout your life dyke
phobia is a fear of justice and el faro
phobia is a fear of freedom you'll have
to stay clear of the Netherlands if you
have Dutch phobia a fear of the Dutch
you phobia is a fear of hearing good
news but don't tell them there's a cure
some phobias can be unexplainably
bizarre such as Laveau phobia which is a
fear of things to the left of your body
Laura phobia is a fear of otters did you
know that authors hold hands whilst
sleeping so they don't drift away from
each other how can something so utterly
adorable be scary pen Faro phobia is a
fear of your mother-in-law one New
Scientist reader discovered a telephone
helpline dedicated to helping those with
a variety of ailments one of these with
telefono phobia a fear of telephones
xantho phobia is the fear of the collie
yellow xantho phobics can be afraid of
the sun daffodils yellow paint and many
other yellow objects in some aggressive
cases of xantho phobia sufferers are
even afraid of the word yellow saamne
phobia is a fear of falling asleep some
the folks fear falling asleep because
they associated with dying it can also
relate to a feeling of lack of control
or from suffering repeated nightmares
some saamne phobes are simply scared of
losing time whilst sleeping think that's
difficult to live with it's not as bad
as front mo phobia Freneau mo phobia is
a fear of thinking nama phobia is the
fear of being without mobile phone
coverage
it may sound ridiculous but it has been
well observed by researchers and is
actually one of the biggest phobias our
survey in the UK reveals that 5th
four percent of Britons suffer from nama
phobia sufferers fear losing signal
running out of battery or simply losing
sight of their phone papa phobia is a
rare fear of the Pope or papacy it is
closely related to jairo phobia a fear
of holy individuals or sacred objects it
is usually related to a traumatic
experience associated with the Pope
Pagano phobia is a strong fear of beards
the term has been used since the 1850s
British journalist Jeremy Paxman
recently accused the BBC of suffering
from Pagano phobia after he was
criticized for sporting a beard whilst
presenting Newsnight similarly helado
phobia is a fear of bald people
but the cruelest phobia of all is
hippopotomonstrosesquipedaliophobia this
ironically named phobia is the fear of
long words now that's just mean
sufferers of
hippopotomonstrosesquipedaliophobia are
scared of the name of their own phobia
and finally a nutter de phobia is the
fear that wherever you are whatever
you're doing there is a dog watching you
unfortunately the fear isn't real it was
made up by Gary Larson but that hasn't
stopped many people from believing there
are actual sufferers of antipodal phobia
thanks for the view subscribe for more